I just have a value system that says
it's not about the money it's about
building something you believe in it's
about serving other people it's about
work ethic it's about showing up and
working you can tell the world to eat
less and exercise more and it will work
for every single person ever that's ever
done it but the reality is the vast
majority of the world will not do that
I'm gonna tell you a story and this
story pisses people off need motivation
watch a top ten with believe nation
[Music]
he's Tom bill you and here's my take on
his top ten ruse a success vol ten enjoy
[Music]
okay let's kick off with rule number one
take the pain so I would get kicked in
the face and I would do something really
dumb I'd be called an idiot told how
stupid I was and then I just be like all
right I need to recenter and that just
became my obsession I need to be able to
emotionally get back to complete neutral
so fast that you don't even see a
register on my face to do it how do you
do that literally practicing so I could
get I could be in a situation where I'm
being berated or or illegitimate ly mess
up and it costs money and it's like whoa
that's on me and it is nobody's bad but
my own and I realized that what most
people do their strategy is to deflect
it it's your faults not my fault yes so
I started thinking of this as a metaphor
people are throwing gold at me they're
throwing it really hard and I can put a
shield up and deflect it but then I lose
that piece of gold if I drop my shield
and just take the pain let it hit me in
the head then I bend down and go this
thing which was me being stupid there's
a lesson here and now I have this piece
of gold but the whole thing is I have to
be defenseless so I have to own it I
have to take it I can't fight if someone
is like this to this day if our team is
like hey there's something we need to
point out to you I'll do this I square
up to it I want them to know like hey I
want to hear it I want to know like I
want to be literally physically open I'm
not gonna close down I'm gonna do
everything I can to square off to open
myself so that they know I'm receptive
to the criticism right because that's
the nugget of gold what I know is it's
gonna hurt it's gonna sting yeah but if
I can emotionally recenter so fast you
don't even see that I went through
something now I can just process how do
I take this information you've given me
and get better rule number two find
fulfillment I went through the pain of
living the cliche of money can't buy
happiness early so that was the very
thing that gave birth to my true
financial success so I wasn't through
that though so as most people will never
experience what it's like to come into
crazy wealth yeah it is it is a really
funny moment and funny is the right word
it's it's fun but it's also funny in
that when I was growing up part of the
reason I wanted to get rich was I looked
at those people with admiration and I
didn't
look at myself with admiration so I
thought oh well if I can get wealthy
then I will look at myself with
admiration this would be amazing and
then when I got the money by then I had
changed myself fundamentally as a person
that I had earned so much self-respect
and so much self-worth that by the time
I got the money I didn't I wasn't
looking for anything from the money
other than it is dog great facilitator
it will let you do extraordinary things
but it won't make you an extraordinary
person and won't make you feel any
differently about yourself and because
the money came literally like that
because we had paper wealth so I was a
worth hundreds of millions of dollars on
paper but I just cannot stress enough
that's meaningless in your real life I
was driving you know at one point a
beat-up Ford Focus my wife and I had to
share it had a leaky exhaust and yet I'm
worth at that point I was worth tens of
millions of dollars but there were
employees that were living far better
lives and I was from a financial
standpoint
so that's paper money no bank account
money came in an instant and so it was
about I don't know six years into our
journey and we decided to take a small
investment to diversify so it's a pure
founder liquidity moment and because the
valuation of the company was over a
billion dollars you can imagine even at
a small percentage just the raw number
of dollars is in sanity so all the
sudden I was fantastically wealthy but I
was like it is so in fact this this was
how that day went so everyone I said
earlier you beliefs values identity
habits routines right these are the
things that make people up and I just
have a value system that says it's not
about the money it's about building
something you believe in it's about
serving other people it's about work
ethic it's about showing up and working
and I value myself for that so on the
day that the money hit it hit it like I
know 8 a.m. in the morning or something
and my wife were both in the gym and
she's like what are we gonna do today
and I was like what do you mean I'm
going to work and she like couldn't wrap
her head around aha she's like whoa
we're gonna go to the Lamborghini dealer
yeah she's like come on we've got to
like go do something we've got to
celebrate and I'm like there's no
universe in which I don't show up for
work today none under no circumstances
so if you were to ask my employees when
did the money hit the hell do
I have no idea they knew that it did hit
but they didn't know what day because I
acted completely the same and the thing
I want people to understand is I feel
the same so all of the like things that
I believe about myself to be good
I still believe to be good I earned them
I earned them by doing the hard thing
time and time and time and time again I
know how much I'm willing to serve
people and my family and myself and all
I just know I've done it for years and
years and years so when it came to do I
buy an island and retire or do I double
down it came down to what will make me
love my life the most and the reality is
the thing that would make me love my
life the most because it would still be
fun to just go home be with my wife but
the thing that made me love my life the
most is to do the things that are
fulfilling and I think fulfillment has a
very specific universal formula and that
formula is work your ass off to get very
good at something that you care deeply
about that allows you to serve not only
yourself but other people that's it you
got to have all of it rule number three
use your potential as Buckminster Fuller
said there's nothing in a caterpillar
that tells you that it's going to be a
butterfly and welcome to the human
condition that's the truth of what it's
like to be a person you're hoping that
you turn inward and see some sign some
glimmer some gift that you have that's
been bestowed upon you that you were
born with that is your very birthright
but there's nothing you were born
hopelessly average and the sooner that
you accept that the sooner that you
accept that you were no better than
anyone that came before you and everyone
that's going to come after you but all
of us have potential and so the question
becomes the question you have to answer
with your very life the question that
your actions will answer what are you
gonna do with that potential will you
actuate it will you bust your ass to get
good will you get so good over time that
you can play
the great where you get so good that
people look at you with awe can you get
so good that you become the excuse that
other people use not to try can you get
so good that people have to dismiss you
as naturally talented can you get so
good the people refuse to believe that
they can get that good can you work so
hard
gaining a set of skills and driving
yourself day after day to get better
never accepting who you are always
pushing yourself bored always demanding
more and seeing the beauty in what you
can become and knowing that even today
as a caterpillar with nothing with
nothing to indicate you become a
butterfly can you become the butterfly
do sheer force of will because if you
can become that you become a beacon of
hope not for other people for yourself
because you prove that there really are
no limits and as Walt Disney said you
may not realize it when it happens but a
ticking the teeth may be the best thing
in the world for you why because it's
the thing that's going to make you react
it's the thing that's gonna hold you
down it's the thing that is going to
make you say never
no more I refuse to accept this about
myself I refuse to accept that I'm
average I refuse to accept that I can't
be something more I refuse to stop when
something kicks me in the teeth I refuse
to stop when people hate on the air tell
me that I can't do something I refuse to
be dictated to by anyone even my own
potential I refuse to be held back by
anything least of all me rule number
four find your why and for me it was i
gripping a morbidly obese family my
uncle essentially ate himself to death
when I was 12 years old and it was scary
and sad
my mom is morbidly obese has been my
entire life my sister's morbidly obese
has been almost her entire life my dad
at one point was morbidly obese and then
lost weight but it was like that's just
where my family lived yeah and so I was
like they're going to die far sooner
than they need to and there's this great
mother Theresa quote nobody will act for
the many but people will act for the one
and so I just needed to wake up every
day and think about my mom and my sister
and that was it and I thought I can show
up every day and fight for them it's not
about the money anymore I can fight for
them also if you want to learn how to
have more confidence check out my 254
confident series the link is in the
description below and it's free there's
a gap between who people are and what
they tell you they want to accomplish
rule number five achieve mastery here's
this may be the biggest problem we face
as a society people don't remember that
skills have utility they let you do
something you don't learn to build a
house to impress your parents you learn
to build a house so people can live in
the house you build and once people
understand that like holy SH you're
building this house so somebody can live
in it build a home in it have a family
be sheltered from storms like it's a
real thing man and so all of that effort
and energy went into I have the chills
right now is so you can create that
moment for yourself for other people it
is it is something so much more than
going to architecture school which maybe
you went to because your parents wanted
that and they they were architects and
so you do that thing for that and you
forget the whole reason you became an
architect was to build houses and so
once people realize oh I'm putting all
of this time and energy to build these
things because they let me do something
what do I want to do
what do I want to give what do I want to
create when you look at skills from that
perspective it is like it is being a
superhero it is being a superhero you're
going to collect these abilities these
abilities actually let you do something
the fact that Superman can fly allows
him to save people allows him to do
things other people can't do we all have
this opportunity to become capable of
the extraordinary to be able to do
things other people can't do and that
feels so good rule number six take
ownership I'm gonna tell you a story and
this story pisses people off and it goes
like this my wife who happens to be
British big it up for England let's say
that she is with her mom and she's in
the bedroom that she grew up in she's
all safe and sound the doors locked the
alarm is on her mom's in the next room
making sure that she's safe but right
then a meteorite comes screaming through
the atmosphere crashes into her bedroom
and kills her whose fault is that I know
some of listen to my content
I will tell you that right now now if
people don't know me everybody goes to
it's dumb luck divine providence it's
nobody's fault
how could you blame yourself well let me
tell you how I could blame myself and
when you hear the reality of this and
you realize that I am in no way shape or
form being hyperbolic it actually is my
fault
here's why I know right now there is an
organization that track what are called
near-earth objects in fact I'm on the
board of the XPrize one of the prizes
that they're trying to raise money for
is for this problem to track all these
known objects and to find some way
lasers planted nuclear explosions
something to make sure that if something
is ever on a collision course for Earth
that we can stop it literally four
weekends ago I had a chance to vote for
this to say this should be a prize and I
didn't so now not only have I never sent
a dime of my money to help I've never
sent an email with encouraging words
I've never called them up
to tell them what I think they should do
now I literally voted against them so if
a meteorite happens to kill my wife I
don't have anyone to believe in myself
that's so apparently true now I think
it's the right decision
I think the putting the time and energy
into something that has such a
vanishingly slim possibility of actually
happening makes no sense
you have to know where to put your
energies all of us have a finite amount
of energy so you at some point have to
triage and decide what are the things
that I'm going to attack I'm far more
worried about my wife getting into a car
the likelihood of her dying is almost
certainly going to be at this point
something to do with heart disease or
something to do with an aneurism things
like that
it most certainly isn't going to be a
meteorite crashing through the roof and
killing her but if it did I wouldn't
waste time blaming anyone else now the
key here the key I wouldn't beat myself
up over it I would be crestfallen my
wife is my everything it would be a loss
Oh devastating I don't even want to
comprehend it but I just wouldn't waste
time blaming anyone else because the
reality is and let this come home your
life is the exact reflection of the
choices you have made love your life
great you've made awesome choices hate
your life I'm sorry you've made bad
choices but the good news is you're in
control rule number seven have clarity
take us a little bit through quest for a
few minutes what made it work like what
did you do that was crazy that other
people didn't do our mantra was you can
tell the world to eat less and exercise
more and it will work for every single
person ever that's ever done it but the
reality is the vast majority of the
world will not do that and we already
know that right so people wouldn't
saying that for like 60 70 years so
we're moving in the wrong direction so
our thing was don't change behavior
leverage it so we already know people
will eat things they want to eat you
can't stop people from eating a
chocolate chip cookie so the question
was could you make a chocolate chip
cookie that was actually good for them
so that metabolically was actually
advantageous to eat that cookie could we
bust our asses that hard to make that
thing and so it wasn't easy but now we
had a mission we wanted to end metabolic
disease now when you have that clarity I
know people are going to eat things
based on taste purely so we know we have
to address that which is why we made
snack foods instead of like you know
coming out with broccoli and
you know we just seemed exactly good we
made chips and so but if you called
quest's and said hey I want to get in
shape what should I eat our answer was
boiled chicken breasts and steamed
broccoli because that's the truth yes
right so we're not trying to pull a fast
one we want people to know they can
trust us we know where our products fit
in you when you absolutely have to have
a chocolate chip cookie eat our
chocolate chip cookie rule number eight
be patient you jumped into this startup
situation because I'm not getting from
you that business was a driving force
for you as a kid it was about art and
expression yes 1000% I am NOT a born
entrepreneur yeah not in the slightest
and I part of the reason that my
philosophies are what they are is
because I have lived them so when I talk
about the you know having a negative
voice it's because I have one and it is
aggressive I want to talk about
anxieties because I had anxiety when I
talk about being able to become an
entrepreneur it's because I had to so I
didn't have the instincts in fact from
an instinct perspective I didn't have
any and I had to learn all of that now I
would say I do have good business
instincts because I've trained them over
time but I certainly didn't have them in
the beginning and in the beginning of my
business career the and this is real and
I really want people to feel what I feel
when I say this the only contributions
that I would make for probably the first
two years of being in business the only
contributions I would make to a
conference call were to say goodbye and
I remember looking forward to that I was
finally gonna get to say something but
because at least I knew enough to keep
my mouth shut when I didn't know and I
didn't understand I didn't want to look
stupid so I would just be quiet I would
listen and learn am very grateful to the
guys that gave me the opportunity they
would let me on the call so I was often
in rooms that I probably would never
have been allowed to be in if I'd been
in a traditional company but because it
was a startup they just kept letting me
listen in on phone calls and stuff so
that ended up being really really
extraordinary for me but yeah I had to
learn to be an entrepreneur rule number
nine get better every day here's the
hard truth about getting great it takes
time and dedication it takes a
willingness to accept that you're not
yet good
it takes the ability to stare at the
places that you know that you're weak to
really look at those things and not let
it affect your sense of self-esteem and
not let it affect your sense of
self-worth so that you can still get the
momentum going but you have to
understand that in the beginning we're
all terrible and as Henri
cartier-bresson said your first 10,000
photographs are your worst and so the
thing that really makes great art are
the people that continue to push and the
people that continue to work and face
how inadequate they are and really
understand that at the end of the day
greatness is a craft greatness is a
process greatness is a habit greatness
is the little things that you do every
day
overtime going out every day unafraid of
whether or not this is one of the 10,000
terrible things that you're gonna do
it's being unafraid to make those
mistakes as being unafraid that you're
not yet great and as Marianne rad maker
said courage doesn't always war
sometimes courage is the quiet voice at
the end of the day saying I will try
again tomorrow
and that's it if you want to be great
that's what you have to do you've got to
get up again tomorrow you've got to be
willing to face another day you've got
to be willing to accept that you've got
to get through the bad ideas before you
can get to the good you've got to
understand that you have to start as an
apprentice you have to start as a person
going and getting tea and you have to
accept that that's the job that you
should be playing that you should be
working for somebody else you should be
looking up to somebody else's seeing
what they can teach you because what you
know is that
that you're there to get through the
10,000 bad photographs that you need to
get through to ultimately achieve
greatness and if you make the
catastrophic error that's so many make
to try to tell the world that you're
extraordinary today to try to get the
world to follow you and look up to you
and think you're something today because
the people that living in
that's today
the ones that listen today the ones that
spend every ounce of their energy
amassing mastery getting better every
day working their asses off to improve
their skill set to relentlessly look at
the things that they're not doing well
to understand that they have to break
themselves down and get rid of all of
their ego before they can really find
greatness those are the people that we
remember so if you want to be remembered
if you want to achieve real greatness
you just need to have the courage to
show up every day and take another swing
take another photo try another task do
something that scares you and do those
little things over and over and over
until you win and rule number 10 the
last one before our very special bonus
clip is become unstoppable as Oprah
Winfrey said what you dwell on is what
you become
once you understand that humans are the
ultimate adaptation machine and you
understand that the brain actually
builds faster and better connections
between the things that you think on you
will begin to understand that it is
incredibly important to be thoughtful
about what you think about it's
incredibly important to pick a direction
that you want to grow and to decide who
you want to become and then make that at
the center of your focus your thoughts
your time your energy and if you look
inward or if you look outward and you
don't like what you see remember what
Jim Rohn said if you don't like how
things are change it you're not a tree
and that's the beauty that's the
beautiful thing about being a human we
are so plastic and we can change so
dramatically we are so good at adapting
that we forget that's literally what we
do
but if you can take control of that
process if you can grab ahold of it and
make it your own if you can make it your
daily obsession to make the most of your
potential to pick a very specific
direction to pick an end goal and end
state and end identity and work your way
backwards find out the steps that you're
going to need to take to get there to
execute and have the willingness to put
in the work to have the willingness to
be both the sculptor and the clay to
understand that the suffering that comes
with that of changing yourself of making
yourself into something great is the
suffering well working
it's a suffering that you should embrace
it's a suffering that you should run
towards because in that suffering you
can become any thing you want so start
to dwell on that well on a vision of
being great dwell on a vision of you
accomplishing your goals well on a
vision of you having done this amazing
thing that you want to do dwell on an
image of you being willing to sweat and
bend yourself in half and break if you
need to and bleed when necessary to
become the vision of yourself you always
knew you could become dwell on that and
nothing can stop
now I've got a special bonus script from
Tom on how to have a mission that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the three point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
question number one what are you going
to work on getting better at every
single day number two what is your why
and number three what problem will you
gain clarity on this week I want to tell
stories that empower people period sim
blasts so my thing is if Disney can
create the most magical place on earth
could we create the most empowering
place on earth not me physically like a
Disneyland but by telling stories both
nonfiction through social media and
fiction through comic books movies TV
shows could I create an ethos that was
as clear and easy to recognize as Walt
Disney's magic that was about
empowerment and so that's we're about so
there will be some element of we're
reading scripts and being producers and
attaching things and just getting things
produced but the the real thing is if
Disney were founded today I think
there'd be a huge social component and
there there's it's not a mistake that
Walt Disney at one point was considered
the most famous man in the world and the
US government literally would send them
on goodwill missions to other countries
so there's just something about when you
have an ethos that people can believe in
when there's a face to the company and
it's not just a corporation there's
someone to believe in there's someone to
get value from even if you're not
consuming their product like there's
just people gravitate towards that now
in the era of social media and I have
the same feeling I have now that I had a
quest which was it's the right message
at the right time and so given where
everything is going so we started two
years ago the word impact now is like
everywhere and it's because that was we
could see like emotionally because
that's where I was I wanted to make
impact and I could see that that's where
the world is going like people just want
to make impact and Millennials feel that
but gen Z is obsessed by it and so I
think that there's just I'm on a
collision course right now to make
content that Gen Z is gonna be changed
by and so that that is really what I'm
about is is creating the content that is
going to define
culture
if you want more time bill you check
that the top 50 rules video made on him
as well the link is right there next to
me I'll see you there the only credit I
will give myself is when other people
break and give up and stop
I just don't the thing that gives you
the most energy in life